this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and I am incredibly excited to
be coming to you live from VidCon in
this ridiculous mansion that I wish I
could show you more of because it's just
absolutely insane and luckily we have
one of my personal favorite creators and
probably the greatest productivity
expert on YouTube in this day and age
and that is Thomas Frank Thomas thank
you so much for being on lawyer
interviews youtubers and answers their
legal questions yes no probably I can't
believe you called my house insane
though you know you have a very
interesting style and a one might call
it Trump ass I'm really rich yeah VidCon
just brings a lot of craziness
well so why don't you tell some of the
legal eagles out there a little bit
about your channel because I think a lot
of people could really benefit from the
kind of stuff that you are an expert in
and you talk about all the time on your
channel yeah so primarily I focus on
academic success and productivity it's
not just for students anymore but it
definitely started off as a student
focused channel originally it was all
college info geek branding which is my
website and as time went on I realized
high school students middle school
students teachers young grads all kinds
of people were watching the videos and
as I moved out of school I realized a
lot of the same techniques we use to
learn effectively in college translate
to being an effective employee or an
effective entrepreneur yeah what have
you so now it's kind of hard to describe
exactly what my channel is other than to
say I hope people become more capable
whether it's getting the career they
want building their financial base and
becoming self-reliant or just improving
the way that they learn and get things
done yeah I think that's a great way of
describing it it's it's impossible to go
to your channel and not become a more
efficient and productive person so I
definitely recommend everyone check out
your channel I understand that you are a
business person in yourself and
you have you know taken some of the
tools and systems that you created for
college and have turned that into a
whole business in and of itself right I
am a business yeah we've got I think
seven people on the team right now Wow
so it's kind of crazy you know this
business literally started in my dorm
room during a summer job and now it's
seven people five of which are in Denver
and then we got a couple of remote
contractors so it's it's been a wild
ride and there have been many nights
staying up googling you know esoteric
legalese to figure out if I'm doing
things correctly or not and I hope I am
but well let's take this opportunity to
talk about some of these sort of general
things that either you or people in your
situation have come across yeah I've
actually got a couple of things in mind
so the first thing I want to talk about
is working with contractors yeah because
I work with an editor now and he works
nearly full-time with me though he may
be taking on some extra contracts here
and there on the side right I've got a
few other people who work on nearly
full-time and then a few people who work
just a few hours a week yeah and what a
lot of people always ask when they start
you know working with editors working
with contractors is what defines a
contractor who's independent from an
employee and I mean as you know there
are many differences from the business
person's perspective right an employee
you have to provide benefits you have to
provide a whole host of other things
you got payroll going and with a
contract it's it's really just you know
a 1099 at the end of the year if you're
American and you know either a handshake
agreement or written contract and that's
kind of it so from the perspective of
the person running the business it's a
lot easier to do the contractor outright
often yeah and I think you hinted at
some of the repercussions that come as a
result of making that distinction
between someone that you're working with
and saying that they are an independent
contractor versus an employee there are
of course the the benefits that you have
to deal with but there are all kinds of
legal protections that are afforded for
employees that are not afforded to
independent contractors and there are
tons of tax implications too and I wish
I could give you a really satisfying
answer that here are the three things
that you must
but unfortunately in most states and
under the the federal government as well
there are tons of different standards
depending on which jurisdiction you're
in and on top of that almost all of the
standards have dozens of different
questions that you have to answer in
terms of weighing one way or the other
and there's there's no bright-line under
the federal guidelines the US government
tends to break it up into three sections
there's behavioural control there's
financial control and then there is the
relationship itself yeah and you're just
weighing a bunch of different factors so
in terms of behavioural control if the
employer whether you're employing an
employee or an independent contractor
has the right to define how the person
does their work that leads to more of an
employee than an independent contractor
okay
whereas if the person who is doing the
work can control the manner in which
it's done if they use their own tools if
they have the ability to start and stop
whenever they want that's more
indicative of an independent contractor
versus an employee yeah on top of it
there's a question of can they be fired
at any time or if they have to stay for
the duration of the job and ironically
if you have the right to fire them
whenever that's more of an employee
relationship really yeah if you okay
have the right and the obligation to
finish the job that's more of an
independent contractor because generally
the independent contractor is more of a
person who's hired for a specific job
right and that leads to some of the
financial considerations is the second
overarching question including the the
financial control of the the worker if
the worker has the ability to make
decisions that will affect the
profitability of that specific job that
is more of an independent contractor so
like someone like a video editor for
example they could choose to work all
night and get the job done or they could
choose to work whenever they want and
those are decisions that can affect the
profitability of the job which makes
them more of a contractor correct
correct and you know the big one
traditionally has been
are you allowed to work with other
people right so part of the classic
independent contractor is like a plumber
that owns Bob's plumbing company and
right he might work with you and he
might work with a whole bunch of other
people and that kind of financial
freedom is something that is indicative
of an independent contractor
relationship we think of employees as
having one job you show up 9:00 to 5:00
you get a salary and you can't work for
anybody else you're not really supposed
to moonlight whereas an independent
contractor is generally someone that can
work on their own hours can work for
whomever they want and are they're paid
by the job instead of you know a salary
now I do have a question there sure is
that determined on whether or not they
have the option to work with other
clients or whether or not they literally
are so say you know I've given someone a
contract that effectively buys up all of
the time that they would be willing to
work normally yeah but they still have
the freedom to go work with somebody
else if they had the time or if they
wanted to work 80 hours a week or
something that could still be a
contractor situation right yeah it's a
great question and for the most part it
is based on their ability not the actual
on-the-ground status quo of what has
happened so it is the is the ability to
work for other people yeah not just
whether you know they have actually gone
out and gotten other clients or have
chosen not to so for the most part an
employee is someone that doesn't have
the ability one way or the other they
are stuck with their employer yeah
and then you know that goes right to the
nature of the relationship which is the
third thing that the the IRS and the
federal government looks to which can be
defined by things like the contract just
because you write in the contract with
someone that they are an independent
contractor or an employee that's not
dispositive but it's certainly good
evidence one way or the other because we
like to sort of reward the meeting of
the minds and we assume that if you sign
the contract that you have agreed to
those terms and that's good evidence
that you have agreed to that particular
relationship right and of course you
know the law is what what it is
so just because you've written it in a
contract doesn't mean it's true but the
UN helps to
find that relationship yeah exactly and
then classically along with that
relationship or there's the question of
benefits and if you provide them to the
worker then that is another piece of
evidence that they are an employee
rather than an independent country so if
you start providing benefits out of the
goodness of your own heart or something
that would actually start to move you
into that employee classification no
good deed goes unpunished in the legal
world okay that is that's definitely how
it can go okay so I have one final
follow-up question for you and this or
people who are just working on their own
maybe they have contractors maybe they
don't but I would say the majority of
youtubers out there are sole proprietors
yeah at least the ones in the u.s. right
maybe there's an equivalent overseas but
you know you are the business you know
you are a businessman so the profit of
the business is your paycheck and that's
kind of all there is to it so for those
people what is the benefit of
establishing an LLC or some other kind
of like legal entity for your business
that separates you from it yeah is a
great question and there are a lot of
myths about it it is really fairly
simple because as you as you say as a
sole proprietor if you incur debt on
behalf of your company or you do
something wrong and you incur liability
for a contract or some tort that the
person who's been wronged can come after
you personally so the point of having an
entity at all is to shield liability so
that if someone files a lawsuit they can
get all the assets of the company but
they can't come at you and your personal
assets and so that can be a very
important thing it's it's effectively a
type of insurance to make sure that
there's a barrier between what your
company does and and what happens to you
and it traditionally historically in
order to get that kind of protection you
had to form a regular corporation which
was taxed when profits come in to the
company and then taxed again when you
take that those profits out and you take
a salary yeah as a double taxation yeah
and that is a that is a very American
thing ironically a lot of European
countries don't have quite that system
of double taxation
and one thing that most states have done
is created sort of a hybrid system which
is an entity that provides some
liability insurance but from a tax
perspective you don't have to pay double
taxation and it's called a what's called
a pass-through so the profits come into
the company they aren't taxed at the
company level but the taxes at the end
of the year are considered your personal
income and so you pay personal income
taxes on the profits that come to you
yeah so from a creator perspective the
reason you might want to create a LLC is
to shield yourself from potential
liability from crazy people that are out
there or you know maybe lawsuits that
you might get into it allows you to have
that same kind of legal protection while
only paying taxes once as income tax
when it comes to you so financially
you're still you're still the business
essentially but legally you are not
exactly I've heard that it's a myth that
that liability protection is bulletproof
yeah
that is definitely the case when you
form an entity whether it's an LLC or a
corporation what generally business
people need to do is they need to have a
separate business account and you have
to be very careful about separating all
of your business things from your
personal things because there's a
concept in the law called piercing the
corporate veil yeah where the court will
say you're not really two separate
things you've mixed your own money with
the corporations money and as a result
we're going to disregard the corporate
form and we're just going to go after
you in particular so you know if you
have if someone has questions about them
there are some really good resources
online that will help you form an LLC
and explain the process yeah but the
last thing you want to do is go through
the hassle of forming an entity only to
basically make it null and void and lose
that protection yeah well I know when my
accountant told me is have a separate
business bank account for personal bank
account and then up from there separate
you no credit card that you pay with
your personal bank account and then a
business credit card you pay with your
business bank account and that also
makes the account a lot
- yeah because you can use those apps
that just pull in the bank account
statements and automatically just you
know reconcile your transactions for you
essentially yeah you're not picking and
choosing which ones are personal and
business yeah I totally agree if the
business credit card goes straight to
the business account then really the
stuff at the end of the year is super
easy because you just send your
accounting information for your business
accounts to your accountant and they can
figure out all the tax implications
right from there yeah and you're all
good to go so you can't help but bring
productivity tips wherever you go Tomasz
everyone is gonna be forming entities
and streamlining their finances I can't
thank you enough for coming down and
dropping some productivity wisdom bombs
on all of us legal eagles despite our
interest in the law and I highly
recommend everyone to check out Thomas's
YouTube channel this is really just the
tip of the iceberg and the Thomas makes
everyone far far more efficient than
when they walk through the door so
Thomas thank you so much yeah and thank
you for the legal answers ok that's a
wrap everyone hey thanks for doing this
interview Thomas you know Thomas have
you ever heard of Skillshare it's an
online learning platform with over
30,000 classes I think you'd really like
it but but what's that you you have a
skill share class already it's called
the productivity master class how to
create a custom system that works it
teaches people how to transform their
personal and professional life by
creating simple customized productivity
systems yeah I guess that does sound
pretty good I mean I guess people should
go watch that ok fine smarty pants but
did you know that legal eagles will get
two free months of Skillshare when you
click on the link below
well they do no no I did I don't care if
you have your own code they should use
my code because clicking on the URL
below really helps out this channel you
know the one that that we're on right
now you know the the free premium
Skillshare membership gives you
unlimited access to must know topic so
you can improve your skills and learn
new things so you know people should
click on the link and get two free
months and start learning to think like
a lawyer today yes yeah even you thomas
frank who i am definitely talking to in
real time right now